[Music]
the most fundamental idea at the heart
of modern Psychotherapy is that in order
to heal ourselves from our neuroses in
the present we've got to understand what
went on in our childhoods
though this thesis makes impeccable
theoretical sense there's one enormous
problem with it Amnesia simply put
almost no adult remembers a single thing
that happened to them before they were
three years old countless days and
nights a succession of complicated moods
Sensations and events will have vanished
Into Thin Air like a library of precious
books that sent up in smoke or dumped
unceremoniously into the sea furthermore
most of us remember very little of what
went on before we were seven
this may seem like an obvious point but
it has momentous implications a period
that we've identified as extremely
important is also going to be entirely
nebulous another basic fact of every
childhood is that even though the past
may have been extremely strange and
regrettable it will also in key ways now
seem rather normal and Beyond easy
analysis or questioning our childhood is
quite literally what we've grown up with
and as we know what's always been around
has a habit of not signaling its Oddity
we might sense that something was
peculiar around our caregivers but to
really get a proper understanding of
what these people were up to tends to be
far beyond our ordinary Powers we prefer
to think of something else and to run
fast in an opposite direction
this fixes us in a conundrum which
entrenches our neuroses but there is one
extremely useful way to make progress we
should look at ourselves in the present
and start asking ourselves questions
everything we need to know about the
past is actually contained in what's
going on for us right now we don't need
to try to remember all sorts of things
that have in reality escaped our
memories totally we just need to check
in on who we are today the legacy of the
past will be active rich and vibrant for
better and for worse at every moment of
our actual adult lives so one of the
first questions we need to ask ourselves
as archaeologists of our past is what
day to day in the adult world we are
afraid of
let's imagine a list of someone who is
asked to complete the sentence I am
terrified of
I'm terrified of being thought an idiot
of being found ugly and unacceptable of
being humiliated mocked and rejected I'm
scared that people will be extremely
nasty to me now what we dread at the
hands of everyone we meet nowadays is
inevitably going to be a version of what
we once feared at the hands of very
specific caregivers in a very specific
and yet very forgotten childhood
this gives us a huge amount to go on
indeed it offers us nothing less than
the tools for our recovery it means that
we can take our list as an
archaeological map to guide our thinking
self-questioning might go like this
someone terrified you of being an idiot
so who might it have been and how did
that happen someone found you ugly and
unacceptable so what might have occurred
here someone has it seems arbitrarily
humiliated mocked and rejected you does
that ring any bells someone probably
gave you an experience of extreme
nastiness is this somehow familiar
though we might not be used to thinking
in this way with such prompts at hand
Rich and vibrant thoughts may rise up
from the unconscious we might get a new
perspective on our caregivers and on
what we underwent framed in this way we
might see with Newfound Clarity that
quite a lot more was going on in those
early days than we generally like to
imagine the what will be the next step
we'll need to go back over the past with
a lot of patience and courage while also
bearing in mind that what we've been
projecting willy-nilly onto every man
and woman in the present and every
difficulty we face in the here and now
actually had very particular Origins
which the more we understand them the
more we will feel liberated and
unburdened our future won't have to feel
so constantly difficult or fear Laden
once we can trace back its real
difficulties to a point of origin a
Psychotherapy is always insisted and
promised remembering truly will set us
free
if you liked this film you can download
our app just follow the link on your
screen now